okay so House of the Dragon episode 6 is
now here and the brand new episode has a
lot to break down in it filled with
Easter eggs new characters and a lot of
things that alter what happens in the
books we're here to explain it all said
before the days of the Mori show we
unfortunately can't carry out a DNA test
but we all know who the father of
raniera's kids is hollow and strong got
it going on and though he's only briefly
appeared in the series so far he's
making a lot of noise he was spotted
briefly at aegon's second born day as
well as in the streets of King's Landing
and now my man's gone from a night in
the streets to a night in the sheets now
the book shouldn't be taken as gospel
and though I'll talk about what happens
in it it is important to bear in mind
that there's been a lot of secondhand
accounts that have been compiled by the
maesters they all there forever who took
renera's maidenhead with some saying
that Damon did it Kristen was the one
and Harwin is also mentioned as well
Harwin was known as Harwin break bones
the strongest man in Westeros and also
the heir to harrenhal which we saw in
the prologue of episode 1. it said
Kristen rejected her at one point and
she ran up into the night which is where
she bumped into Harwin who ended up
being the one who did the deed in the
source material the pair got it on and
this burned Kristen who ended up
becoming bitter about it though he
knocked renira back he was deeply in
love with her and he ended up unleashing
the Sanger during the tournaments at the
wedding the show changed things up and
had him beating people up at the banquet
but it was at this event that he bested
Joffrey lovemouth Joffrey never again
Consciousness and the character then
died six days later Arwen strong was
also at this tournament too and you the
rumors about him taking that b card
Kristen smashed him like it was a thumbs
up button he broke his collarbone and
elbow and from this point he was
nicknamed Harwin broken bones whereas
initially was break bones due to his
strength the Bucking show clearly put
forward the idea that raniero's kids are
his and this causes a lot of issues in
the Kingdom because raniera is an
accident line it means that her children
will follow the line of succession and
Allison's will be completely overlooked
the children on Lanos and they're
completely missing the Valerian hair
that all the other kids including Damons
ended up having I know there was the
usual backlash that you tend to get
whenever White characters are played by
black actors but I think they change it
with the valerians and Powers the story
even more because the kids are wider
than Gandalf in Return of the King
there's all wins
[Music]
Owens
he's harwin's we've actually seen
something similar in Game of Thrones
before and hair color is also how Ned
realized that Cersei kids weren't
baratheons due to them all being blonde
it made it more likely that they were
actually Jamie's and this Dad of
parentage of course carries over to the
targaryens and valerians who all have
distinctive hair colors now the episode
itself centers around The Heirs of the
dragon and all the children that now
exist in the realm as well as their
claims to the throne the episode
features a 10-year time Jump and it's
based heavily on the midsection of Fire
and Blood chapter 12. because of the
recast we've now gone from arguing about
who the true Heir is to who true runnier
and Alison tall though Millie Alcock and
Emily Carey are now out the show the
former has said that there has been
talks they could return in season two so
they may end up filling in what happened
between the decade that we're missing
out on now much in the same way that we
have a recast in runera we also have a
complete change in her mind stay too
whereas once she was completely against
having children we now learn that she's
on her third some people might find it a
bit jarring seeing someone new in the
role but I think the creative team do an
excellent job of getting us used to the
idea that this is now an era the opening
shot is of her face and we get a slow
pull out as Rey tries to push out the
baby you know the scene someone Echoes
the birds seen me watched him as I go
through and as Emma said this is almost
like a battlefield for the royal family
I think being there for the birth and
then getting a one shot of her walking
through the castle is such a smart way
to get us invested in here and we see
she struggles through this literal
uphill climb we see her in the most
vulnerable position that we've ever seen
her in before but watch as she still
soldiers on because because she doesn't
want Alison dictating her life renira
knows she's only called for the child to
be brought to her because she wants to
confirm her suspicions and doesn't give
a sh about her or her child might even
be mad that she had to spend all those
nights with the King whilst Rey was off
with the most handsomest dude in the
Kingdom so sir Kristen it's not you
anymore and they are complete opposites
and we see this in the way that they're
presented with Rey being a broken woman
whilst Allison's wearing her best dress
she's got a full face of makeup servants
tending to the most minuscule things on
her clothes and meanwhile renira looks
completely disheveled she has to huddle
up the stairs whilst her after birth
leaks out on the floor with no one
helping her Beyond her husband lanor we
actually see this trailer she leaves the
Queen's quarters later on demonstrated
by the bloody footprints on the floor
now the greens and blacks are slowly
starting to emerge here and we see this
demonstrating the red and black uniforms
the guards wear outside the birthing
chamber Leno has been request too and we
discovered that he wasn't there for the
birth because he'd been gallivanting
with the guys he's pretty much just
doing what men do in this situation and
being like
terribly painful
which hey I think I said the same thing
to my wife it brought back a lot of
memories for me such as things like the
chord cutting which I don't think I can
show and that's someone who had twins
earlier in the air I think this
recaptured a lot of what went on in a
way that's rarely shown on TV upstairs
we see Lord Caswell who is one of the
first to offer their congratulations
when she goes down Castle plays a big
part in the story and it's important to
bear in mind for where we'll be heading
bit of a spoiler there ruined it but
moving on now this video is sponsored by
established titles a gift that lets you
become like your favorite Lord a lady in
House of the Dragon did you know there's
a traditional Scottish custom to have
landowners referred to as a lord lady or
a lad that's why I was super interested
in this project which allows you to get
at least one square foot of dedicated
land in edleston Scotland it's also a
great way to help out the environment as
established titles will plant one tree
with every single order they work with
Charities like one tree planet and trees
for the future to help with
reforestation efforts so if you pick up
a plot you can refer to yourself as a
lord whilst helping to preserve the
picturesque Woodlands of Scotland now
there also comes a bit of an ego boost
on top of all this environmental stuff
because you're now a Lord leader a lady
you can officially change your name on
things like credit cards plane tickets
your dating profile whatever you want to
do as you can see here they give you an
official certificate and also details
the exact location of your unique plot
number on top of this established titles
have also told me that the first 200
people who use my link below will be
placed within walking distance from my
plot depending on how many of you want
to become a lord lady a LED we can build
our unique heavy spoilerm Kingdom
together you can be like Lord Kevin
spoilers you punk I'll see you jump
establish titles have also put together
a sale where you can get an additional
10 off their massive full sale I've
linked it in the description below and
all you have to do is go to
establishtitles.com heavy spoilers and
enter heavy spoilers at checkout for
that additional 10 off makes for a great
last minute gift you can get yourself
involved in all the house of the Dragons
drama so definitely go check it out in
the description below thanks at the top
of the stairs we see Kristen Cole who is
now clearly Allison's Royal Guard due to
him standing outside her room at this
point viserys also comes waddling in
looking like a shell of his former self
you'll likely notice his arm has been
amputated and maybe he needs a hand of
the king
this arm looked really bad last episode
and we might even get a tease to what's
gonna go next as the guy starts to fall
apart anyway his face is covered in
sores and you can tell he's going bald
because it takes him longer to wash his
face viserys also says this line
do believe he has his father's nose
I feel like this is giving a direct note
to the strongs in the books all of them
were described as having pug noses and
this was one of the family traits I feel
like they're using the show who is your
daddy Alison is slowly watching more
energy to make kids pushing her children
further down the line and she drops this
super cold bit
soon I'll let you make it when it looks
like you
although I'd give a breakdown on all the
kids so you have more of an idea of
these two sides of the family Alison
ended up having four children with air
being egg on the second Elena Eamonn and
Darren all of these kids have something
known as the coloring of the blood of
the Dragon which basically means they
have the bleach blonde look that's
described as showing a True Blood
Targaryen as for Harwin strong sorry
raniera's kids these were jakaris Luke
Harris and Geoffrey leina wanted to name
the first child after his ex lover she
offers but this was forbidden at the
time however the last boy was allowed to
be named after him obviously Alison's
kids hated the fact that their older
half-sister was the one who was going to
be on the throne and they were fueled by
Alison who told them aegon was actually
the true Heir due to him being a male
viserys tried everything he could to
just go back to his train set and he
wanted nothing more than for the whole
thing to blow over he even had Jake
Harris and dare on share a wetness but
not even a little itty bitty titty from
the milk of the floppies could bring
them together glad to learn together
train together you'll certainly form a
lifelong Bond wouldn't you agree yeah he
hopes the courtyard combat will bring
them together but with Rainer taking the
kids in the end we know that won't
happen back with our brothers we seize
an egg has been chosen for the baby and
as we know Targaryen tradition dictate
that eggs be placed in The Cribs with
babies so that they could form a bond
another reason why harwin's kids being
outer would cause issues is because the
targaryens and valerians preyed on the
idea that people believed only the high
Bloodlines were able to ride dragons
this made them appear almost Godlike to
The Peasants but is strong being able to
do this would rock the boat and show
that anyone could the kids are sent to
the dragon pits and you might recognize
this location from Game of Thrones
season 8. it's where the big meaning was
held and where bran the broken was made
King because he told the best stories
now jigaras gets a dragon brought out
and this is Vermax it's important to
bear in mind that this is yellow here
the other works don't describe its
coloring but Max's egg was placed in a
crib with him and due to people
suspecting that jacarus was as strong it
was thought that it would never hatch
Alison even touches upon this with his
line later on in the episode
however it did and because of this the
pair formed a lifelong Bond they beat it
a girl giving me lots of t-rex in
Jurassic Park Vibes and also mentioned
aegon's Dragon Senpai this was a giant
golden one and it actually ended up
being adopted in the Targaryen Banner
aegon is also played by David Tennant's
son Tai and he goes on to do a
homelander later on can't show it but
you know you know the bit where
homelander stands over the city choking
the chicken that's that's what he does
shows he has complete disregard for the
kingdom and also lets us know how he
treat people if he ever got into Power
also got lots of flashes of tommen
stepping out the window and that's the
second thing after She-Hulk this week
that's reminded me of denim from The IT
Crowd he's not nice to his brother
Eamonn and he teases him over the fact
that he doesn't have his own dragon he
comes across one in the books that's
revealed to be Vega but that can't be
the case here as it belongs to Elena
vegar is one of the eldest and fiercest
dragons in the realm and it ends up
killing her which starts an event known
as the red spring now it no longer has a
right air and there's big things coming
with a dynamic that will probably happen
in the next episode this builds even
more of a rivalry between the two houses
and this starts an eye for an eye
mentality that's again a bit of a
spoiler pun if you know the books there
next we jump to the final child Helena
who instead of being allowed to play
with Dragons is studying incest sorry
insects she's not looking at a family
tree Now Alison is clearly getting her
to study different types of beasts of
them so that she can operate in an
opposite Manner and all the children are
very much used as Weapons by the queen
in order to maintain and gain power go
to viserys and I feel super sorry for
the guy at this point he just wants to
sit and build the title sequence but
he's constantly being interrupted by the
bullet in case you missed our last video
we now know what the disease that he has
is and Paddy considine cleared it up in
an interview with Entertainment Weekly
Paddy said it was a form of leprosy and
that his body is now falling apart from
the inside they alter the timeline of
this and actually changed things up for
the show giving one of the major moments
to him instead of Laris in the source
material he had the tongues cut out of
two people who said that Rainier's kids
were strongs Raz larisier is the one who
chops them out this is so that they can
never talk about the job that he gets
them to do later on which we'll talk
more about at the end of the video now
after he had this carried out viserys
ended up getting off the throne which is
where he slipped and cut his fingers
similar to the ending of episode one The
Book said at this point that he got a
fever and it was only when raniera
provided her own personal maester that
she was able to save his life this was
done by removing his fingers and we
pointed out in episode 3 that some were
missing so all in all they've kinda
reordered the events of this with it
happening in the series before the
children were born either way in both
the book and show this left him almost
unable to walk and though he comes to
the baby he spends most of the episode
sat down he denies the suspicions by
Alison fully aware that it has the
potential to destroy the kingdom viserys
unfortunately was a people pleaser who
didn't want to rock the boat and this
inaction led to the house being divided
because so many people gained claims
this makes Alison slowly start to gather
people together including sir Kristen
calls raniera a c next Tuesday he
describes her as a spider who stings and
sucks her prey dry but you weren't
complaining when she was doing the
spider and sucking you dry
it shows how much he's turned against
her and the politics of her getting
married is someone to unite the houses
basically made him do an Eminem when he
was going through his Kim face Rey
married lanor is away to United Kingdom
but instead it's caused a further divide
with him being one of her fiercest
opponents all the politics Alison is
playing slowly poison those around her
and aegon clearly doesn't care about
being the King this is the same in the
book and it's only his mother moving
things around that even keeps him in
line for the running definitely feel
like it's a comment on how pushy parents
can often push their kids down a path
where they end up taking their beliefs
and it shows the kind of person that
Alison has turned into now she is doing
it out of fear because she believes
Runner will have her kids killed so that
in the end there's no challenge for the
throne we all saw how her father was
fired and being alone in this Kingdom
has made her step up and defend those
she loves although the division was
seemingly started up by Alison wearing
green as a declaration of war at the
wedding the books didn't paint when era
out in the best like either a lot of
division came from Rey refusing to call
her brothers her brothers and you know
viserys was just like
sake got across the pentos and we see
caraxis along with Lena's Dragon Vega
Damon flies through the fire in the air
and targaryens are immune to this which
we saw with Daenerys now the source
material explained how Lena and Damon
ended up becoming a couple similar to
what happened in the series Lena was
patrolled to a Sea Lord however he was a
bit of an idiot and he blew all the
money that he had before he came to
driftmark Corliss tried to postpone the
wedding but there was no way to break up
the marriage without there being
Dishonored during this time Damon came
adrift Mark and he apparently fell in
love with Lena though some Buda as being
a Power Play by him to get a new kingdom
Damon was rejected from the veil after
the death of Lady rear and many just
thought it was moved by him to get a
kingdom after losing out on that one
Damon ended up insulting Lena's lover
and he challenged D head to a jewel
which kinda went one way Damon
completely wiped the floor with him and
he ended up marrying Elena just two
weeks later now because this was without
the approval of the king it had the
potential to call was a lot of issues so
the pair flew the pentose on their
dragons before moving to the all Runes
of valyria they tried to see if they
could inert anything but the landscape
was still ashes due to the volcanic
eruption back in pentos Lena discovered
that she was pregnant and she gave birth
to the pair's twin daughters Reina and
Baylor Elena's mother is called rhaenis
and Damon's father was called Balin
hence the names though Reina Elena and
Baylor always kind of reminds me of that
scene in DodgeBall blade
laser
[Applause]
Blazer now there's a great banquet and
they talk about egg on the Conqueror as
well as his Dragon Valerian this was
known as the black dread and it was
written by viserys who also kept its
skull below the red keep the Lords of
lease arising with those of Dawn and
Damon is requested to Aid pentos Damon
just wants to stay in the realm and live
a good life and in the books viserys
even talks about how fatherhood calmed
him down Lena's death of course changes
his mind State and he ends up returning
to the uncle and husband that we've come
to love in the courtyard Kristen trains
hand-to-hand with aegon and amend and
you might notice that they wear green
whilst the others wear red and black
Harwin ends up losing it after he's
accused of caring for the kids like
their his own and he's expelled from the
Night's Watch Kristen did a lot worse
last week and the only reason he was
allowed to stay was because Alison
appointed him as the Royal protector
when he reloans of this Sanji ends up
sneaking through the passage in her room
that she did back in episode 4. she
comes across Lionel and Harwin arguing
over this and I love the way this is
shot but both men stand in their own
spaces with the pillars dividing them
showing how the father and son are on
the opposite side of things this could
also be foreshadowing their deaths in
which a door stops haul when pulling his
father out only at the end will they be
United in death and they end up
returning home to Harren Hall Lane all
shows up drunk and he's accompanied by
sakal who will talk more about in the
spoiler section of the video leina wants
to return to the stepstones after
hearing of the conflict there and he of
course views the victory as a glorious
way to spend his youth against dark air
but he wants what he views as a more
straightforward fight rather than the
backstabbing going on in the Kingdom
there's also mention of a purple head
man which I believe is recalio or in
Dune this was a captain who declared
himself King of the narrow sea and he
dyed his hair purple and used to
sometimes dress as a woman he was in
everything and it said that he had 12
wives who he used to ask to beat him he
also had a fetish for pregnant women and
he might pop up later in the timeline
either way even Damon knows that Harwin
is the daddy and he's clearly bored
longing for the Glory he once had
however he puts his family above that
and stays in the library reading up on
the dragonlords of the past Lena has
made a peace with him not being the wife
he wanted and I think he's gonna feel a
lot of guilt over her death at the end
back with the council we hear the
mention of gravity why was this issue
not brought before Lord Grover well he's
also a Tully Grava served in about
jaharis and viserys with him supporting
the latter against rhaenice when the air
was chosen He also mentioned the
brackens and the blackwoods using any
excuse to spell each other's blood we've
actually seen this in the series already
and the two families voted out during
the cutting scene for anira's hand
runyra ends up suggesting that jakaris
and Helena marry in order to avoid a
Civil War and it's a similar situation
to what Otto suggested to the king he
proposed renira Marie aegon and he was
also well aware of what could happen if
the families weren't United Lionel looks
horrified but the dealers could short by
renira's breast milk leaking viserys
seems on board as it could sort
everything out so let's get him married
and wait for the whole thing to blow
over oh well not gonna happen and you'll
probably be surprised to find out who
Helena ends up marrying very strange but
uh yeah we'll keep that a secret for now
now Lionel tries to resign but for
Sarah's denies this request however he
personally wants to escort us and home
which leads to a plot by Laris that
Alison gets into Laris is actually also
Lionel son and the reason that he cuts
out the tongues of the prisoners is so
that they can't tell anyone he murdered
his own father and brother he says that
the curse could be the thing that's
blamed and there is said to be one over
Harren Hall due to how many members of
the House end up coming to bad ends with
his position open middle finger ends up
gaining a seat on the small Council and
he turns against his family in order to
gain power known as Lara's Club but he
was often overlooked because of his
disability and thus he gained a vendetta
against his own family as mentioned
earlier the book has several accounts by
different people with some suggesting
that Laris was behind the murder however
due to it being a fire there were also
suspicions of Damon it was thought that
he might have used his Dragon to kill
Harwin and this would open things up in
the future for him with raniera either
way Alison wants someone on her side to
be closer to the king and withholden out
the way he'll give her more of an
influence over his actions the tongue
slicing scene was a tough watch and it
actually put this guy above Littlefinger
for me in terms of who the Deads are I'm
back at the birth of Lena's child we
watch it as a similar scene happens to
the one with Emma in episode 1. Damon of
course made fun of the air for a day and
now the shoes on the other foot with him
losing both his wife and child in the
books they described how the baby came
out twisted and deformed and that it
died within an hour of its birth now the
shoulder pics are going to vagar and
begging for death The Source material
does present some of this differently
childbirth was pretty rough for her and
the malformed baby twisted up a lot of
her insides leaving her bedridden for
three days knowing she was dying it said
she got up out of bed and ran out into
the courtyard to fly vegar one last time
however she collapsed on the steps of
the Tower and died before making it to
the dragon Damon said over her and was
joined by renera but I actually prefer
the way that it's done here way more
impactful watching her burn and it's of
course murdered in the burning of Harwin
at his home in harrenhall he says
goodbye to his sons and though he
promises to return sadly we know that's
never gonna happen naranera says they
can also send a letter by Raven to her
lover and this is a basically like the
Westeros version of Adam Levine dming
your bird he's damning your bird a
gagaris has of course also heard the
rumors and he asks if he's a bastard Rey
doesn't answer him outright but she says
you're a Targaryen
[Music]
she goes to Elena and says that the pair
should travel to Dragonstone Elena also
drops his important line you always said
if you were absent from court she would
bore her honey in your father's ear the
book does mention how there were
suspicions that the queen was poisoning
the king now we'll see if this gets
brought up again she returns to
Dragonstone which he was the princess of
and this of course would where the
standoff happened in episode 2. Harren
Hall is burned with both Harwin and
Lionel perishing and we hear narration
by Laris talking about how children are
a weakness this is him referring to
several children in the show and how
their kids have all led to their
downfall this is seen in viserys and all
the stuff with rhaenyra being the air
and it's of course reflected in her own
children which have caused rumor and
speculation to question their legitimacy
Lena also died due to childbirth and
this is a theme that's constantly popped
up throughout the show Harris himself is
also a child of Lionel and every
character has somewhat become bitten by
their kids who watches a raccoon closed
captioning
not
available
and I can't raise the show high enough
now for the next part of the video we
will be talking about some of the
upcoming spoilers so if you don't want
that ruined then I recommend that you
turn off now this is in relation to the
red spring which has a major event in
which several characters die again could
ruin some of the major things for next
week so get the [ __ ] out of here if you
don't want to know say go on get go and
get see a chump anyway the air 120 AC
begins with a big tragedy as Lena gives
birth to her and Damon's child which
we've just seen this is Then followed by
harwin's death and sadly Lenor doesn't
last much longer either he's actually
killed by Lord Carl who he learned was
jealous over him loving another night so
both of valerians are out the way and
neither Damon or an era are married
because of this you can probably guess
what happens next with the pair but this
all happens in about the space of a year
and I know that the next week is gonna
come with several girl punches too but
still look forward to well not really
because I ruined it for you but yeah
hopefully I'll see you there you promise
to come back he promised anyway that's
the video I hope you enjoyed it and
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the episode below by running a
competition right now and giving away
three copies of dollar and thunder on
the 15th of October and all you have to
do to be on the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
we picked the comments at random on the
15th and the winners of the last one are
on screen right now save that to you
then message me on Twitter at heavy
spoilers if you want something else to
watch then make sure you check out our
Brighton of rings of power which will be
linked on screen right now we cover the
highs and lows of the episode and also
point out the Easter eggs in it so if
you're interested in that show I know
there's some of you then definitely head
over there right after this by the way
thanks for singing through the video
hubby Paul I'll see you next time take
care peace